hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation titled the faecal alas days
1 a biomarker for pancreatic exocrine
insufficiency i am xavier q tiers of lab
rats and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by DSR to learn more
please visit www.ccltss.org or call
916-966-6643 on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. sure we will now begin his
presentation
hello my name is Professor Roy I share
with I'm professor of clinical
biochemistry at King's College London
and that until the Graduate also the
scientific director of pathology for
pathology that covered guys Hospital Sir
Thomas's Hospital and King's College
Hospital and we have a center for
pancreatic impenetrability researcher so
what I wanted to talk about in this
webinar is pancreatic exocrine
insufficiency an ex-client disease and
the markers that the laboratory can use
to be able to test and diagnose that
condition so if we start with something
very simple the pancreas itself it is a
glandular organ located almost centrally
within the abdomen and you can see can
be divided into head body and Tyler and
its function can be divided into two
parts the endocrine function which is
the regulation of glucose by the release
they release into the bloodstream of
glucagon and insulin whereas from the
point of the exocrine function which is
what we're really interesting this is to
release the digestive juices into the
small bowel by the pancreatic duct which
comes out almost opposite the bile duct
and these pancreatic juices serve to
continue the folk break down our food
which started in the stomach into the
parts that can be absorbed such as
proteins are fast and carbohydrates so
if we look in slightly more detail to
that I've said that the endocrine
function can be assessed by measuring
glucose itself but also potentially by
measuring our insulin and glucagon the
ex-prime function can be divided into
two parts that part that reduces the
fluid itself and associated with the
fluid bicarbonate
and then the cells that produce the
enzymes that take part in digestion and
as a list on this slide of the enzymes
that are relevant to digestive processes
amylase Pillai plays tricks in I will
mention further detail there was time at
trypsin there was a family of s
psoriasis and carboxy ester razors there
is a last phase which we will come to
later on in terms of its measurement
emphases and there are the carboxy
peptidase if we now consider first
pancreatic disease where you can divide
that into those that present in the
neonatal or early infant period which
really are cystic fibrosis and something
that's termed trap and Down syndrome
which is actually the aplasia of the pen
pancreatic alpha cells and we'll come
back to that in in children and in
adults then you can have three
categories of pancreatic disease acute
pancreatitis and nowadays we know that
some of the acute pancreatitis cases
presenting in children may be hereditary
pancreatitis due to mutations in the two
genes that protect from the activation
of trypsin within the pancreas so that's
the PR ss1 gene the cationic sillerton
gene and thus pink one serine protease
inhibitor Cazale type 1 genes and
essentially these mutations leads of
loss of function and that loss of
function means that trypsin is activated
and destroys cells within the pancreas
there's chronic pancreatitis and
pancreatic insufficiency which again
will expand on further and a pancreatic
cancer which still has one of the worst
prognosis of any of the cancers due to
late detection because of lack of pain
associated with it and there are solar
markers for pancreatic cancer but that's
beyond the scope of this particular
webinar so if we consider that we are
interested in and a few definitions
along the way chronic pancreatitis is a
chronic inflammatory disease of the
pancreas that can cause pain that also
can cause loss of pancreatic function
and that loss may be permanent if the
pancreatitis goes on too long and what
we want to talk about is exocrine
pancreatic insufficiency or epi and in
epi the activation activity levels of
pancreatic enzymes are reduced and this
leads to failure to break down the foods
are leading to mel digestion and to the
malabsorption because the food is not in
that state that can be absorbed this in
itself then leads on signal nutrition
and the typical clinical symptoms
includes the anterior because with the
absence of light base being present in
the gut you are unable to break down the
fats and therefore you get fatty stool
which is what steatorrhea means I said
you can get malnutrition and a first
sign of malnutrition may well be weight
loss you can get abdominal discomfort
because you have undigested food and
malnutrition with all the any conditions
can block the pancreatic duct can also
cause a chronic pancreatitis and this
sometimes can be the manifestation of
pancreatic cancer if the
so tumor is in the position that causes
obstruction of the outflow of the
pancreatic duct and anything that causes
damage or destroys the cells within the
pancreas producing the enzymes can cause
a pancreatic insufficiency if we
consider the epidemiology and the
prevalence it is not necessarily a
common disease most of the data are for
chronic pancreatitis comes from large
phase series and various cross-sectional
studies population-based data is scarce
because its incidence is ranging from
five to twelve hundred thousand and the
prevalence of 35 to 45 per hundred
thousand and it does appear to occur
more frequently in men than in women and
when we look in the next slide and the
causes it may be possible to see why
that's the case
establishing an early diagnosis can be
very difficult because it mimics in many
ways other conditions and in some
patients who develop acute pancreatitis
they go on to progress to chronic
pancreatitis and there's a useful
information for example from the various
associations this particular data comes
from the american pancreatic association
practice guidelines that were published
in pancreas the journal pancreas in 2014
and if we consider the actual etiology
and an idea of the type of incidents
that occur in pancreatic cancer
eventually there is almost certainly a
type of development to it the presidency
type 1 diabetes is around 25 to 57
percent and insight to about 20 to 35
percent and in patients with untreated
celiac disease and in irritable bowel
syndrome then so inflammatory bowel
disease then the prevalences can be very
variable
celiac from 4 to 80 percent IBD from 40
to 74 percent and the GI surgery
depending upon the surgery involved it
can be up to a hundred percent so for
example the neuro endocrine tumors that
can occur tend to occur within the
pancreas and can result in surgery with
variable extents of pancreatic removal
but the biggest causes of manana are the
presence of alcohol alcoholism and
obstruction from the fact that the
pancreatic duct comes out opposite the
gold bar mouths and large amounts of
gall stones can cause it so there is a
variety of cases that may mean that a
diagnosis of epi needs to be considered
so if we are looking to diagnose epi
there is imaging there are invasive
methods and dystrophic methods that have
a risk of acute pancreatitis but there
are also the various lithography based
tests the one could use if we consider
the gold standard and I'll get a bit
more detail of that in the next slides
the direct tests as they're called
because you have to pass to down include
a secret in tank design and test which
is the gold standard the little test
meal which is long since discontinued
and I don't believe you can even get the
test meal constituted anymore the
indirect tests which I will show a slide
on although mostly they are no longer
available the enzymes and isoenzyme
estimation in plasma and serum and then
the various fecal tests including fetal
fat chymotrypsin and the one we are most
interested in in this particular webinar
and that is elastase Wow
so if we look at that gold standard you
have to site a shoe usually using
fluoroscopic control in the duodenum
past the pancreatic duct so that you are
able to aspirate the fluid release from
the pancreas now this is not necessarily
easy I've done many in my time and you
are doing them in very small infants and
children who often need some sedation
but you can't today and significantly
because otherwise they won't actually
produce any fluid and you've secreted
which does exactly what it says it does
it induces fluid secretion and then you
give a pen kizaemon or sometimes known
in the u.s. a Carolyn to induce the
enzyme production and I am always used
to give them in that all their secrets
in the first to get clue flowing and
then Hank kizaemon but others give them
together then you collect fluid usually
for 15 to 30 minutes and analyze for the
constituent parts that make that is exha
kind secretion so the fluid volume the
bicarbonate of measure pH which allows
you to assess the response to secretin
and then some form of indesign
measurements I attended to measure and
analyze and trypsin you can measure
Emily
and like hurts we're in children is
particular useful is because of the
different pathologies associated with
cystic fibrosis and Schwab and diamond
syndrome or pancreatic a please you in
cystic fibrosis you get obstruction
therefore you have a low fluid output
but you have a normal enzyme
concentration it whereas in pancreatic
ecclesia and by definition the cells
producing fluid and normal sort of fluid
volume compared to normal but there is
very very low enzyme concentration if we
now consider why measurement of the
enzymes produced in the pancreas in
blood which would be very easy to do
have disadvantages then we'll start with
amylase
amylase has two dominant ISO enzymes a
pancreatic and the normal pancreatic
which is predominantly saliva about 95
percent and if you separate these in a
plasma song they're roughly 50/50 of
concentration a typical upper limit of
normal is considered to be a hundred
unit per liter and most definitions of
pen acute pancreatitis take three to
four times the upper limit of normal as
being the cutoff values above that being
associated with acute pancreatitis but
chronic pancreatitis may not elevator
plasma amylase to any significant effect
and there are two major problems with
the use of amylase and that is the
ethnicity has an effect on amylase
subjects of an African origin have a
higher reference range for non
pancreatic amylase than do subjects of
any other ethnic origin and we found
this particularly when in the early days
of an th
pthey and we set up an isolated system
for the Medical Research Council the
early drugs caused occasional cases of
acute pancreatitis and what we were
finding was patients with no symptoms of
African origin who had significant
significantly raised her amylase ballots
and these turned out to be of non
pancreatic origin predominantly saliva
and then in some patients you've got a
map of amylase emia which are IgG
complexes which are large and because
they are large they are not excreted as
rapidly as amylase and tend to cause an
increase in the results so there are
disadvantages to analyze lipase has
greater specificity although it's not
specific it is about 80 to 90 percent
derived from the pancreas but there are
certainly more forms and in that tating
women there is a breast milk I so Enzo
it is becoming much easier to measure
now and they're becoming a less
expensive although is it still
significantly greater cost and less
availability than measurement of amylase
it does not however have any effect
associated with ethnicity no prison
would be ideally the candidate it's
approaching lytic enzyme its secreted as
an inactive zymogen trypsinogen and is
activated by itself as it were by
producing well secreted into the GI
tract now because it is a proteolytic
enzyme it has relatively low specificity
for the proteins that is actually
tablets and so acute attacks of
pancreatitis can result in the release
of trypsin and alter digestion
anklets now clearly you do not want that
in a normal state so any active trypsin
that's released into the circulation is
inactivated by binding to the protease
inhibitors alpha 1-antitrypsin or alpha
1 n 0 T ace inhibitors it's really
should be called an altitude map of
bobbili the latter actually being the
biggest proportion of inhibition that
actually occurs the complex is formed
with trypsin and alpha 2 map goblin R
such that this whole molecule is
surrounded and therefore the trypsin
bound to ATM is not measurable but those
bound to alpha 1-antitrypsin can be as
than any trypsinogen which is released
into the circulation most trypsinogen is
not and it's very rare to see it in
adults in the near nights because of
lychee vessels it can be seen in small
amounts in the event of cystic fibrosis
the mutant plugs that block the
pancreatic duct mean more trypsinogen
gets out into the circulation and this
is used in the blood spot screening for
diseases that takes place in the first
seven days of life in the UK that
started around 2006 nowadays of course
genotyping allows confirmation but there
are so many mutations that last count
well over 600 and that almost unbearably
whole gene sequencing is required to
establish from confirm a diagnosis the
panthéon law test was an interesting
Shoeless test as indirect test you give
fluorescein
which is a colorless dye that if she
changed the pH her to an alkaline pH it
becomes an orange green color and
fluorescence so what you give is the
Esther eyes form the fluroscein deloitte
and pancreatic esterase breaks this down
to give lauric acid and the flora c
which is then absorbed the fluorescein
is absorbed and excreted unchanged in
the urine and then you do it over two
days one in which you only give thirsty
the other in which to give fluorescing
deloitte and then you express result as
a ratio between the toilet the results
have a grey zone between 20 and 30 and
importantly it is certainly no longer
available in the pharmaceutically pure
form that used to be sold both in the UK
and the USA so it really made me
consider historic tests a similar one to
that is the NT paba
test an NT Kabbah was an benzoyl
tyrosine a minor benzoic acid and is
cleaved by chymotrypsin and you measure
a patter in the urine in the same way or
you can measure up hava in blood but
again certainly in the UK pharmaceutical
grade antique paba
is no longer available so somewhat
discontinued if we now consider the
fecal tests people that some people
consider to be a silver standard in a
three-day collection although the
reliability of patients collecting three
days of feces is often poor typically to
improve the case carmine red dye markers
were ingested at the same beginning of
the test and when they appeared that was
typically at three dates the analytical
methodology itself was
it needs to evolve burette and was
unpleasant to both patients and staff it
is still carried out in certain research
centers and it is still often
incorporated into drug studies carnot
River City had a good as if were
potential however the analytical
methodology is not robust the number of
enzyme immunoassays that are available
give different numbers there is no
recognized standard and the sensitivity
for chronic pancreatitis is only between
70 and 90 percent and false positives
have been described in a number of other
GI tract diseases so now we've come
around to elastase or to be corrected in
last phase one this is an endo protease
and the steel or binding protein
concentrations in feces are our five
fold higher than in the pancreatic fluid
itself so there is a concentrating
effect in the feces and it has good
stability within a week at room
temperature and longer at minus 20 and
results are low in both obstructive
conditions such as cystic fibrosis and
in pancreatic insufficiency of a chronic
form and in most cases the sensitivities
and specificities fall into the 80 to 90
percent bracket without give some
greater detail of that near the end the
standard cutoff is almost invariably the
same for all methods and is around 200
microgram per gram of wet bites it has
better specificity than climate written
among the guidelines now recommended as
a replacement for a pancreas or test it
is however not valid in liquid stools
because of a dilutional effect you don't
get this fivefold concentrating
effect if the stool is really now
there's a limited number of assays
available there are a number three on
Isis and there is a qualitative immuno
chromatography test and then there is
the only automated essay as a commander
Minister destiny the sheep over by the
FSA the Eliza has been around the
longest
there has to among internal antibodies
to the epitope sites on there are states
the in the chromatography method is a
qualitative test designed to be
potentially and near patient tests and
uses the same antibodies as the ELISA
test the bioserve method Eliza uses two
polyclonal antibodies the outer which is
common in the u.s. to Mono thermal
antibodies and the chemiluminescence
automated USA has two monoclonal
antibodies now importantly the
extraction of elastase from the sample
and that is variable from weighing
methodologies to various suggested
extraction devices and this is simply
the dinosaur in a device which is like a
wand that is then inserted into a chew
in such a way that that to then becomes
the vessel that is placed onto the
liaison X our Iser for testing itself
and these five steps to show that it is
a very simple means of doing the
extraction used at this point in his
previous years I put a number of slides
up showing various reports that have
been published of studies comparing
either elastase with the secret in tests
or with fetal faith but gladly in 2018
there was a meta-analysis which had 14
studies
significant a number of places 428 cases
of epi were 670 controls that compare
elastase with the gold-standard secretin
stimulation test and that had a
sensitivity of 77% and the specificity
of 88% and in another six studies that
compare the last days with the silver
standard infrequent fat they've had a
sensitivity of 96% and the specificity
of 88% and in all places this 200
microgram per gram class off is used an
important bleed the false negative rate
was one point one percent and the false
positive rate was around 11 percent now
pancreatic involvement during the
courses it's not a true bowel disease
has been noted and depending on the
country that studies have been carried
out on the number of cases in which the
last phase of how protective are
requested together install the samples
varies between about 10 and 25%
importantly in transient epi has been
reported with low fever last days in
about four percent of patients with
prone disease and about 10 percent of
the u s-- emotions there was also
obviously a risk of is associated with a
bowel surgery so found you to doing it
in probably about 10 to 15 percent of
cases there are a number of guidelines
that have been published in the last
seven years this was the first and was
saying that essentially if a people last
days was below the limit of detection at
the assay which was the Sheba assay at
15 then there was a very high
probability having exocrine
insufficiency values between 15 and 200
without the supporting imaging results
also suggested epi
whereas a result of weights than 200 was
almost certainly a very low probability
about supplying insufficient the
delightful offspring lazy and pancreatic
Club produces guidelines in 2015 which
stated difficulties in diagnosing epi
and the testing was valuable either
using people fat karma trypsin or
elastics again their values less than
200 ruin a good indication and they said
if the value was less than a hundred
then the EPI was likely to be severe the
European guidelines published in 2017 a
glint of a plateau of 200 and again
going that the a safe example the Stila
Tchibo assay has a upper limit of as a
capabilities of 500 micro gram per gram
so they said it values less than 200
were definitely indicating epi values to
a hundred than 500 excluded it values in
between that is dependent upon other
aspects so to conclude we have looked at
and said secretin and kizaemon is the
gold standard but it's technically
difficult and it's invasive
we know that amylase and lipase let
specificity the vast majority of trypsin
released is bound to alpha 2 and because
of that binding cannot be measured by
amino acid facility is only useful where
you have duct obstruction we know if
people fat is unreliable due to patient
compliance painful law and the NCP MBT
PABA tests are no longer available and
the breath tests that the sometimes
mentioned or discussed the using
carbon-13 labeled trial in I haven't
moved out
because they are not FDA approved the
person owner whereas in that latest
measurement in feces is non-invasive
it's simple and it's reliable in
detecting epi a value less than a
hundred indicates severe disease 100-200
mild to moderate whereas values greater
than 200 virtually exclude PPI and
certainly values greater than about 500
definitely exclude epi thank you for
listening thank you dr. Sherwood for
your informative presentation and as a
reminder speaker will follow up with any
questions you have submitted via email
following this webinar we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Diaz horn for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand and lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye